we now have a trap door for solving Phi
if you know the factorization for n then
finding Phi n is easy for example the
prime factorization of 77 is 7 times 11
so Phi of 77 is 6 times 10 60 step 3 how
to connect the Phi function to modular
exponentiation for this he turned to
euler's theorem which is a relationship
between the Phi function and modular
exponentiation as follows M to the power
of Phi n is congruent to 1 mod n this
means you could pick any two numbers
such that they do not share a common
factor let's call them m and n say m
equals 5 and N equals 8
now when you raise m to the power of Phi
N or 4 and divide by n you will always
be left with 1 now we just need to
modify this equation using two simple
rules first if you raise the number one
to any exponent K you always get 1 in
the same way we can multiply the
exponent Phi n by any number K and the
solution is still one second if you
multiply 1 by any number say M it always
equals M in the same way we can multiply
the left side by n to get M on the right
hand side and this can be simplified as
M to the power of K times Phi n plus 1
this is the breakthrough we now have an
equation for finding e times D which
depends on Phi n therefore it's easy to
calculate D only if the factorization of
n is known meaning D should be Alice's
private key
it's the trapdoor which will allow her
to undo the effect of e let's do a
simple example to see all of this in
action say Bob has a message he
converted into a number using a padding
scheme let's call this M
then Alice generates her public and
private key as follows first she
generates two random prime numbers of
similar size and multiplies them to get
n 3127 then she calculates Phi of n
easily since she knows the factorization
of n which turns out to three thousand
and sixteen next she picks some small
public exponent e with the condition
that it must be an odd number that does
not share a factor with Phi n in this
case she picks e equals three finally
she finds the value of her private
exponent D which in this case is two
times Phi of n plus one divided by three
or two thousand and eleven now she hides
everything except the value of N and E
because N and E make up her public key
think of it as an open lock she sends
this to Bob to lock his message with Bob
locks his message by calculating m ^ e
mod n call this see his encrypted
message which he sends back to Alice
finally Alice decrypts his message using
her private key D accessed through her
trap door C ^ D mod N equals Bob's
original message M notice that Eve or
anyone else with C N and E can only find
the exponent D if they can calculate Phi
n which requires that they know the
prime factorization of n if n is large
enough
Alice can be sure that this will take
hundreds of years even with the most
powerful network of computers this trick
was immediately classified after its
publication however it was independently
rediscovered in 1977 by Ron Rivest Adi
Shamir and len Adelman which is why it's
now known as RSA encryption RSA is the
most widely used public key algorithm in
the world and the most copied software
in history every Internet user on earth
is using RSA or some variant of it
whether they realize it or
not its strength relies on the hardness
of prime factorization which is a result
of deep questions about the distribution
of prime numbers a question which has
remained unsolved for thousands of years
[Music]